Ra's al Ghul is coming across all of us
if half of the stories that I have heard
about Ra's al Ghul are true we will all
pay none of a clean coal with us there
is a prophecy a man that doesn't perish
at the blade of Ra's al Ghul will become
Ra's al Ghul
shadow Suicide Squad rides again
Oliver Queen is the arrow what are you
going to do now I'm gonna stop it
stay the hell away from you hunt the man
they call the era
people are being murdered your days as
the arrow are finished and maybe I
should be Ra's al Ghul
you've made us criminals liars and
victims you mr. Queen are not a hero
you're a villain I got you now you son
of a [ __ ]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my arrow trailer breakdown
biggest takeaway WTF Quentin Lance in
the arrow cave and Brandon routes
character Ray Palmer also finding out
who Oliver is this is a lot of
speculation but you know just just in
case mild spoiler warning four episodes
16 through 18 right actually 19 arrows
like one episode ahead of the flash
they're going to be out of sync it's
gonna be weird don't worry about it it
opens up on the League of Assassins and
this is actually this is gonna be really
exciting for those of you that totally
geeked out on Rachel in the League of
Assassins the back half of arrow is
going to be a deep dive into the League
of Assassins they're gonna tell the
story the history of the League of
Assassins a lot of that's going to come
from Rachel goals mouth from the demons
mouth the rest of it's going to come
from Merlin and team arrow snooping
around Merlin's quote in this trailer
about the legend of the man that
survives racial goals bleh he said the
same thing at paleyfest the man who
survives the blade is destined to become
Rachel goal like a lot of things there's
a double meaning there it is a
double-edged sword make all the jokes
about that you want yes that that's
awesome you can take over the League of
Assassins that's great but it's also
kind of a curse like you have to take
over the League of Assassins and as much
as Oliver is is kind of a question here
he doesn't have a choice that leaves the
question as to how he's going to get out
of this sentence how is he going to walk
away at the end of the season not being
the next racial goal and still having
his head attached to his shoulders
really the biggest WTF from these
flashback scenes is seeing shadow alive
just because we see her in the
flashbacks we see her live like regular
shadow that doesn't mean a lot that
could mean a lot of things if you just
go based on the timeline she's dead when
Oliver supposedly seeing her so that
flashback could be from somewhere
further in the past he could be
hallucinating or it could be some crazy
comic-book twist where she has a twin or
she's a clone I know a lot of people are
asking about Roy possibly being cloned
this year that was something that Teen
Titans did but we haven't really gotten
into cloning on arrow yet and until they
do it it's really hard to tell whether
or not they ever plan to get that
fantastical it's like Marc Guggenheim
used to say no superpowers on arrow but
then he changed his mind so until they
quote unquote change their mind about
cloning and stuff like that we don't
know if they're going to do it this
scene here is a team arrow at a Russian
facility so it looks like they go back
to rush
like they did in season two here's a
couple scenes from suicidal tendencies
that's the Suicide Squad episode it's
also the Diggle Lyla wedding episode if
you're big fan of the green arrow Black
Canary comics then you'll recognize this
as like an homage to Black Canary
marrying Oliver Queen in the comics if
any of you are shippers you can make as
many jokes as you want about olicity
larissa dee quantum superposition here
where Oliver is at a wedding in full
tuxedo next to Laurel and felicity and
no i don't think that Oliver is ever
going to get married while Stephen Amell
is playing the arrow no matter how many
seasons it gets the coolest thing about
these Suicide Squad scenes are that
they're bringing Cupid back like she's
going to be part of the Suicide Squad
they've already been a couple pictures
of it here we get some cool Adam scenes
we'll get to see him uses atom suit a
lot more he's got a lot more special
abilities that they just haven't shown
off yet remember they're gonna do a
spin-off where he's gonna be a main
character so and I think in order to get
people pumped up for that to get people
excited for the spin-off they're gonna
try and showcase all the things that he
can do flying is cool yes but this arc
blaster it looks like there's gonna be a
lot of fun too what I'm really
interested to see is is what Cisco does
to the suit to make it better it doesn't
have anything to do with shrinking of
course WTF here he finds out who Oliver
is it would not be a new season of arrow
if new people didn't find out all of her
secret identity Marc Guggenheim already
said that Oliver and Ray Palmer aren't
gonna see eye to eye just in terms of
the way that they fight crime I think
they'll use that to lead into why Ray
Palmer goes off to a different city to
form a different super team like they'll
just have like a fundamental difference
of opinion so it'll be like okay fine
I'm just gonna go over here and do my
thing you stay here and do your thing
and for those that are asking no
Felicity is staying on arrow no matter
what happens Felicity will always stay
on arrow she's not going on the spin-off
she's not gonna go on the flash unless
it's just a cameo here's a shot of Doug
Jones he's playing death bolt the
character from the comics you may
remember him as Abe Sapien from the
Hellboy movies the episode that he's
starring in is the episode that someone
is supposed to die in it could be Roy it
could be masayo son it could be Quentin
but it has been confirmed someone is
definitely dying Quentin here meeting
with Rachel goal this is really exciting
Quentin is kind of going to go against
team arrow as racial ghouls said in some
of the previous promos the city will
turn
against you he's talking about Oliver
like Oliver's been trying to make his
city better but it doesn't seem to be
working and everyone is going to wind up
hating him especially Quentin here for
what happened to Sara for laurel and
oliver line to him the crazy thing here
is that you have Oliver fighting someone
else in his costume in like a green
arrow costume that begs the question is
the city really actually going to turn
against Oliver like is this person
masquerading as him trying to do good or
is it someone trying to tarnish his name
here's Quentin pulling a gun on Laurel
so there's actually getting a little
crazy thian Roy get a little busy and
then here's the big final WTF Quentin
breaking into the arrow cave it's
possible that racial ghoul tells him
where to find the arrow and it just so
happens to be in the foundry and he's
like hey wait a minute this is the
building that my daughter's old
boyfriend owns here's a shot of Nyssa
going up against a ratio goal remember
she is pissed that she is no longer the
heir to the demon here's a very WTF
looking amanda waller don't you just
wonder what's happened to her she looks
like she's been like holed up somewhere
or being held captive here it looks like
Thea's getting ready to kill Merlin are
definitely contemplating it so as much
as [ __ ] is hitting the fan on the flash
the same thing is happening on arrow
Stephen Amell said this really
interesting thing he said that Oliver is
seriously contemplating using the League
of Assassins to accomplish his goal of
cleaning up the city it seems like it's
all ended in failure but inside his head
Oliver's thinking what could I do with
the resources of the League of Assassins
at my disposal so it's not gonna happen
right away but he will work up to the
point where he's like maybe I should
become the next Ra's al Ghul but I think
honestly I think all of us don't believe
that he's going to become the next
racial goal he's still going to be the
arrow when season four starts so what is
gonna have to happen for Nyssa to become
the air again for Oliver to be able to
you know step away from this very
strange situation with fresh alcohol and
still be alive don't forget new episode
of the flash episode 15 is on Tuesday be
sure to subscribe to get my video for
that i'll post it right after the
episode airs episode 16 of arrow is
going to air on Wednesday so
everything's coming back there will be
no more breaks between now and the
finale it's going to be a straight push
the finale so don't worry about that so
if you guys want to watch this trailers
again and just you know put them on loop
here is a link to the flash trailer you
just watch it over and over again it's
going to be so awesome back Tuesday
night so the
back for new episodes and you can click
here for my PaleyFest breakdown they
talked a lot about season two wally west
coming all kinds of crazy stuff thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow now let's all do the thing
you